I'm working on a very small book about
Abraham Lincoln which is a bit like
saying I'm hailing a taxi cab on Madison
at five and Madison and fifty fourth at
five o'clock in New York because
everyone is writing books about Lincoln
but I'm writing a little book about
Lincoln and what he learned at critical
moments along his journey and why those
lessons matter today and I realized that
some of the lessons that he learned
lessons of detachment and forbearance
and compassion and patience were lessons
that are relevant both at an individual
level to each of us today or too many of
us today but also relevant on a social
or even global level and when can learn
them interestingly enough and in this
sense the book is unusual I think
through stumbling through as he said
once in the middle of Civil War through
falling to his knees because he had no
other place to go and so I'm
reconstructing Lincoln's stumbles and
time on the kitchen floor if you will or
time on the cabinet floor cabin floor if
you will in order to try and understand
how leaders all of us as teachers and
parents and citizens can can be can be
made into better citizens and parents
and teachers and leaders rather than
being born I think we suffer a little
bit nor moment right now from leaders
are born where are they you know how did
they get the Oracle at Delphi and we're
paying less attention to how we're made
step by step two to two steps forward
one back into better and more effective
leader